あの これからのサマディ瞑想の話し
なんですが それでサマーディ瞑想のやり方として四十種類のカンマッターナが教えてるんですね
で この前も説明しましたから
このサマーディっていうのは心の統一性であって
それはなんとか工夫して心を統一することはできるんです
ですから 別にその四十種類に絞らなくても
他の方法でも構いません
で 世の中でだいたい集中するために使う方法っていうのは
ものすごい過激的な強烈な対象を作るんですね
作ったらまあ強引に自動的にそこに心を集中しちゃうんですね
例えばものすごいでっかい声
音で音楽聴いてると まあ他の音は入らなくなっちゃうし
あまりにも明確にでっかい声
音で聞こえるんだから
まあそう聞いていられる状態になっちゃうんですね
それである時間はまあずっとっていうことはではないんだけど
そこだけ聞いていられます
それからまたすごいこの迫力ある何か見ていると
例えば祭りを見て で 祭り見たらものすごいでっかい大げさな出来事でしょうし
で そこでまあそこにすぐ心が惹かれてしまうんですね
で それでみんな気持ちよくなっちゃうんですね
楽しいと その楽しさ 気持ちよさっていうのは
そのある一つのものに心がつけられたんだから生まれるものなんですね
ですから 集中力っていうのは悪いことであろうが
いいことであろうが 何かに集中しちゃうと結構楽しみが生まれてくるんです
で そこからまあその論理なんですね
その論理でとことん心が心を集中して集中して持っていっちゃうと
どんどん楽しさが強調して多くなっていっちゃいます
だからといって どんなものでも見て集中してすればいいかというと
それはそうじゃないんですね
例えば音楽にしたら いきなりでっかい音で綺麗な音で耳に入っちゃうとすぐ惹かれてしまいますけど
ちょっと時間経つと混乱が生まれてくる
あるいは自分の好みの音楽でない場合は
もう二 三分以上は聴いていられなくなっちゃうし
で そこでいくら自分の好みの音楽と思っても
ずっと聴いているとどんどん面白さがなくなってきて
つまらなくなって嫌になってしまいますから
この集中力できる時間というのは決まってるんです
ですから 短い時間で集中力できる量だから
そんなに大胆な集中力出てくるわけじゃないんです
祭りにしたっても まあ一時間
二時間でもう呆れてしまう
疲れてしまう もう帰ろうということになってしまっちゃうんですね
だからこの世の中で集中できるものっていうのはいくらでもありますけど
やっぱり時間決まっていて
それから混乱が いら立ちが生まれてきて
集中力が壊れてしまっちゃうんだから
それほど役に立つところまで集中力を成長することはできないんですね
ですから そこら辺科学的にちゃんと見て
長い時間 何に我々の集中力できる何か対象ないかということは
対象を真剣に選ばなくてはならないんですね
だからこの気持ちよくなるということは
この集中力的なところっていうのは
この普通の世の中でもあるし
宗教 一般的にどんな宗教にもあります
いくらか気持ちよくしてくれないと
宗教には人が入ってこないんですね
ですから どんな宗教を見ても
人の心を落ち着くような
いわゆる一時的でも何か集中力を作る作られるような
なんとか工夫しているんですね
ですから このまあ南アメリカの方でね
まあ大変一般的な音楽やらね
まあなんかある牧師神父さんがなんか CD出しちゃって
それは一番売れがいいんだと
なんか予想以外にまあバカみたいに売れてるんだとか
で 話もありましたけど
で それなりにこの教会にしたっても
その集まる人々に合わせて音楽変えちゃうんですね
例えば黒人の教会だったら
そちらでやっている音楽と白人が集まる教会の音楽は違いますからね
で とにかくそれなりにそれぞれの人々の気に入られるような状態で工夫するんです
で まあですから どんな宗教にもそうやって何か集中
一時的に集中するような方法をとっているんです
そこで仏教も同じことで
仏教の世界でもいろいろ宗教的なお祭りあるんです
その宗教的な祭りやると
まあそこで気に入られて
どんな人でも簡単に参加してしまっちゃう
まあ日本でもいっぱいありましたけどね
そういうのはなかなかなくなってしまっちゃってね
神社の祭り ほとんどそれだけでになってますけどね
まあ京都とかそういうところではいくらかはやっているんですね
まあいろいろ今残っているのは花祭りぐらいかもしれませんけど
それでもやっぱり田舎のお寺にしか
のお寺でしかやってないんですね
まあ都会にいる人々は
で まあ糸を切れてるんだからね
で あっちこち飛んでるだけで
どこへ行くか どこに落ちるかわからない
糸切れた凧のような人生ですけど
で 威張るとこじゃないと思いますけど
いくらかの文化的な何か足場がね
あった方が人間には自分の生き方
それなりのをコントロールできるんです
もう一つ この お経を聞くことを正命ですね
それももういくらか人々の心を落ち着いてもらうと
集中してもらおうと ということで
ですから 別に経典の内容は別にどうったことないし
どうったことないではなくて
もう気にしなくてもいいんです
音だけじっと聞いて落ち着きましたと
それで気持ちよくなるんですね
そうやってこの集中することっていうのは
いくらか楽しさが生まれてくる方法で
で 未だに世の中でただそのレベルで止まってるんです
この心集中して苦しみがなくなって楽しみが生まれてくる
この現象 この具体的な心の働きをね
ものすごく上手に使ってとことん心を育ててみましょうという方法は
まあ遠い昔 仏教ではまあかなり考えていたんです
それまた捨てられてしまったんですけどね
だから人間というのは
この科学的なものは捨てる過程で頑張っているんだから
どうしようもわかりません
だけどとにかく仏教で言っちゃってるサマタ瞑想というのは
とことんもう最高なレベルまで心を集中する方法を見つかりましょうと
そこで対象を選んで種類のカンマッターナですか
カンマッターナっていうのはこの宿題ですね
集中するための対象という意味で
あのカンマッターナ考えてるんですね
なんで種類に限ったかというと
やっぱり 危険性はないようにということで
また長い間できるようにと二つと考えているんですね
他のものはいろいろ危険性あるんですね
それから邪見が生まれてくるんですね
だからこの 仏教は智慧の教えだから
集中力だけでは足らないし
智慧が生まれてこなきゃ
だから集中力プラス邪見といったらもうどうしようもないんですね
それだったらない方がいいんですね
集中力は 集中力全くなくて
でも頭がいいんだというのは一番優れているんです
それをもう認めているんです
集中力があって頭が悪いと言ったら
もうただゴミと同じ 戻ったことないんですね
ですから一番いつでも必要なのは智慧なんです
集中力ではもう感覚的にはすごく楽しみであるということで
なぜそういうことを言ったんですか？例えば鬼を観察すると
集中力が生まれてくると
はっきりと鬼が自分に存在するように実感できるんですね
それでその人は必ずしも誤解しちゃう
やっぱり鬼がいるんだと
だって私には見えますから
そういう現象が心にあるんです
だから実際になくても
頭でずっと長い間考えて続けると
そのものは実際にあるのごとく見えるんです
経験できるんです それ集中力の結果なんですけども
集中力の結果として実際にないものを自分が認識するようになってしまっちゃうんですね
例えば どんなものにもオーラがあるんだという
西洋的な変てこりんな考え方ありますね
この西洋から出てくるものは全てすごいと思ってますけど
そうじゃないんです ものすごい全て原始的なんです
科学の中でも原始的な方がものすごい多いんですね
今 中国にあの核兵器の技術を盗まれたんだと泣いてるんですね
アメリカが だってそれぐらいのことだから
そんなに頭良くない 自分の秘密ぐらいはちゃんと守れる
何言ってるんですかって
中国人簡単に盗まれるんだと
だから原始的でもいいところなんですね
何を盗まれたというと
やっぱり小型の核兵器作る技術だと
だから自分だけで小型核兵器作って
すごく力強くみんなにあのみんなに暴力振るえるんだと
それを中国人に盗まれたら困るんだと
だから人に盗まれただけで弱くなるんだったら大した技術でもないし
だから自分の技術ぐらい
それぐらいのことを大事に守られない人々は何者かとも思えるしね
で それだったら普通だったらすげえなというのは
アメリカではもう大変な反逆罪で厳しいんですけど
で またずるずると中国の実際対立したらちょっとどうかなとかね
考えたりして またそれちょっと置いておいたりすると
まあそんなレベルなんです
とにかく普通の子供の心のレベルとは全然成長していないんです
だからもうヨーロッパから来るものはなんだかんだで最高最強というのは
俺もあんまりにもバカバカらしいことで
ちゃんと判断して理解した方がよろしいし
だからこのオーラの話にありますけど
どんなものにオーラがあるんだと
そこでオーラがあるんだと見れば見えるんだと思って
じーっといろんなことを見るとなんかそんなものようなものが見え始めるんです
何のことなく その人に見え始めたら
その人ありますと 確実に
と決めつけちゃうんですね
しょうがないんですけど
それは それで私たち えっ
そんなことあるんだったら見えるはずですよと
あなた方には見えませんだけど
私に見えるんだからと
だから認めなくちゃいけないんです
それはすごい非科学的なんですね
なぜならば  100人の人間の中で一人に見えて
499人に見えません
故に事実ですよということだから
どう見たっても事実じゃないんですね
誰かに幽霊が来て話しかけてくれるんだと
亡くなった人が喋ってくれるんだと
でもどんな人にも亡くなった人がいるんでしょ？先祖が
でも話しかけてくれないんですね
たまたまある人に話しかけてくれるんだから
それは一般的な真理として認めてあげなくちゃいけない
それ認めてあげるバカの人々の考え方はまたおかしいんですね
知識人だ知識人だと言いながら
もし死んだ人が話しかけてくれるんだったら
もうかなりの人々に話しかけてくれるはずなんですね
そこでどういう働きかというと
ある人があまりにも情があって
執着があって 人が亡くなってもその人のことを考えたり
考えたり 考えたり どこにいるんですか
どこにいるんですか なんとか何とか話してくれるんだったらどうかどうかとかね
そういう方向へ思考を持っていくんだから
そういう幻覚を起こしちゃうんですね
だからちゃんと会話できるようになっちゃうんです
だからこの瞑想の世界ではこういう問題があります
だからこの仏教論理学を書いたダルマキーティというお坊さんが
そこら辺でこの人間の認識を理解するところで
ないものでもちゃんと観察し続けると
実際にあるのごとく心に認識を受けるんだ
というふうな認識のシステムを分析しているんです
だからそこら辺 論理的に知っている人々は別に瞑想では間違わないんです
だから仏教はこのものすごく嫌になるほど真剣というか慎重なんですね
やたらに何でもいい 何でもやれということは言わないんです
だからこのインドではいろいろ瞑想がありましたけど
そこからお釈迦様が仏教に取り入れているのは呼吸の瞑想だけなんですね
他のものは全部もう一つも使ってないんですね
断食行もあるし またいろいろ行をやって集中する方法もあります
そういうのは一つも入れてないんです
そうやってこの四十種類がありまして
そこでも幻覚を起こします
その四十の中でもはっきりと
起こすんだけど そこで間違うようにはしてないんですね
今日のお話はこの四十の中でこの最初の十種類
それはカシナと言うんですね
カシナ十種類あります
カシナっていうのは意味なんですけど
瞑想のことだから大変大事なところなんですけど
このカシナってどんな意味かとさっぱりわからないんです
調べようもない これパーリ語でもないし
サンスクリット語でもないんです
うーん まあ簡単に一つ一つ説明していきますけど
一番目はパティカシナ
パティカシナ これはこのこっちは地片と書いてまで土片なんですけど
これカシナっていうのはやっぱりこの目で見て瞑想する方法なんですね
目を通して心を集中するための種類なんです
で パティカシナ パティ
土片というのは このまあこちらも書いてますから
この三十センチぐらいの
あの円形で丸い何かものを作るんですね
そこにこの土色を まあ土ですね
まあそういうものを塗っても構いませんし
あの土色のもうこの紙でも壁紙でもどっちでもいいんです
見たら土だと分かればいいんです
で そこ色で一つ持って
まあ分かり まあ見やすいところに置いておいて
そこはジーッと見続けるんです
それで派手な絵だったらすぐ苦労しなくても見られますけど
じっと見続けるとすぐ楽になってしまうんです
で この場合は中道的で
別に嫌でもないし まあ好きということでもないし
だからあのちょっと自分の側であの苦労しなくちゃいけない
で 不思議なことは あの見れば見るほどどんどん面白くなってくるようなものなんです
この派手な絵よりは違うところはそういうところなんです
瞬時にすごいと思うものは決してそうじゃないので
それは心の働きなんです
例えばよく光るのは金紙ですか？本物の金ですかというと
どちらですかね 金紙の方がもっとよく光っちゃうでしょう
だから でも本当に意味があるのはやっぱり金そのものなんですね
ですから この人間に 我々にとってはこのすぐ気に入ったというものはもうほとんど意味がないものなんです
ゆっくりゆっくりと気に入っている
気に入っているものは
まあ長く持ちます やはりそれは人生についてもそこら辺は気をつけた方がいいんですよね
すぐこのまあ気に入ったっていう
これっても危ないんですね
ほとんどの場合はあまり当たらないんだよ
その瞬間の直感であれ気に入ったっていう
それにはもう観察した結果で気に入ったというならば
それはもうしっかりしていて
滅多なことで変わらないものなんですね
それでこの土色というのは
やっぱりどんな人間にもどうしても落ち着くはずなんです
我々は土から現れてきて
土の上で生活していて
まあ生きているものだから
いつでも見ているもんなんですね
激しい花とかね そういうものとは違いますから
だからなんとなく心が落ち着いていくんですね
そういうことで 土の色の丸い円形のね
三十センチぐらいのものを作って
それを前に置いておいて
それはじーっと見ているんですね
で 大体このサマーディ瞑想だから
あの かなり時間ずっと続けて見る訓練をしなくちゃいけないんです
まあ瞑想の世界ではものすごく準備がありますけど
あの そんな簡単にできるもんではないんです
例えば まあ仕事の合間で
あの あ ちょっと一時間ありますから瞑想する
そんなもう落ち着きがなくてね
頭の中で計画いっぱいあったりして
これはもう全然瞑想にはならないんです
だから落ち着いて よし
やるぞという気持ちで
もう全部忘れてやれるぐらい心の準備があるんです
そういうわけで この瞑想する前のいろいろ基本的な準備がたくさん書いてあるんですね
まあ自分がいろいろ世俗的ないろんな仕事やらいろんな関係ある
それはもうやめましょうと
ちゃんと休み取りなさいと
離れなさい それから体にいい食べ物を食べて
もう余計に体の体力やらいろいろあると
また瞑想できないし 体力ないとまた瞑想できないし
で そこら辺も気をつけて
それから自分を落ち着けるような場所を選んだりして
それから服装もすごく綺麗にして
でも簡単単純でなければいけません
大変おしゃれして瞑想しちゃうと
それまた混乱しちゃうんですね
おしゃれはまたダメ だからといっていい加減な服もダメなんですね
ちゃんと服を着て で おしゃれもしないで
椅子に座っても構いませんですけど
で 静かなところで自分の心落ち着くところで座って
それから座るときも二
三時間座れるぐらいのね
ずっと続けて 本当は八時間ぐらいですけどね
でも最初は八時間はいりませんですけど
まあ一応最初でもやっぱり二時間
三時間はまあ座っていられるぐらい用意して
あの 座って瞑想する ですから食べてすぐダメ
時間あるんだからといって
食べないでもダメなんです
だから食べて飲むものは飲んで
いくらか体が落ち着いたところで手洗いにも行って
まあそれだったら まあ二時間
三時間は水飲まなくてもいられるんです
で それで頭なんか洗ってないと
それまたダメなんです
頭洗って 足を洗って 顔を洗って
歯を磨いてやらなくちゃいけないんです
いろいろ準備いっぱいあるんです
頭なんかちゃんと洗ってないと
あっちこっちで痒くなったりすると
それかかなくちゃいけないでしょうに
歯をちゃんと磨いてないと
一時間ぐらいになってくるとすごい気持ち悪くなってくるんです
[咳]顔を洗ってないで
もう汗から脂やらね そんなものあったまんまでやっちゃうと
もう気になって気になって集中はできません
だからそういうふうな
この前の全部準備用意して
それからもし誰かが話して話しかけてくれる状態ではそれはダメ
完全にカットして というふうな感じでやらなくちゃいけないですね
そこでやり方なんですけど
この土だったらそれ土色なんですけど
この土だとずっと自分で何も考えないで
その一言葉をずっと繰り返しちゃうんですね
パーリでは言ってるのはパテヒカシナだから
パテウィパテウィとかね
この土に大地に言う何かの言葉
そこで繰り返しやすい土
土ですよと言ったって
もう日本の方々にも繰り返しにくいかもしれませんだけど
私はわかります パーリ仏だったらパテウィメダウィもういろいろたくさん言葉ありますけどね
まあ念じやすい言葉で
そういう言葉でずっと見ながら念じてるんです
念じてるといろいろ妄想が出てこないし
そこでどんどんどんどん見ているものを見れば見るほどどんどん面白くなってくるんです
いろいろ変化が起きたり
いろんなものがいろんな変化が起きるんですね
その変化には驚かないで
落ち着いてずっとパテウィパテウィパテウィと見続ける
そこで自分が集中しているかないかってことはわかります
気持ちよくなってくるんだから
興味が出てくるんだから
この見ているものは動き始める
波が出始める それから見えたり見えなかったりもする
それからなんかもう光ってくる
時々その中でっかい穴が見えたりもする
いろいろなんかいろんな変化が起きちゃうんですね
で そういうもので自分が落ち着いていられるかないかっていうのは
自分の勝負でいろいろ変化あっても何のことなく平気でずっとやってずっと見ているんですね
そこでこのまあ注釈書ではある一つの瞑想法しか書いてないんですけどね
注釈書で書いてる方法っていうのは
これ自分が集中したかないかっていうことはチェックするんですね
このチェックする方法っていうのは
もうたまたま目を閉じるんです
目を閉じても見えるんだったら
まあ一つまあうまくいったということなんです
目を閉じても見えるんだと
このカシナの前にこの5番目に書いてるところ
このミミッタという層というところありますね
この瞑想っていうのは瞑想の対象なんですね
そこで 2番目 ウッガハニミって種相ですかね
この種相というものになるまでやらなくちゃいけないんだと
それどういうことかというと
この対象を見てずっと瞑想する
瞑想して たまたま目を閉じてみる
目を閉じても全くあの 30センチぐらいの丸いあの土色のものはそのまま見える
目を閉じているんだけど
自分には見える そこは種相というんですね
あの本なんて言いますか
この主体 本物のある対象をから何か自分が受け取ったと
コピーしましたと心に
だからコピーするのはこの覚えておくことはいつでも起きる出来事を私たちは何か見たら頭の中でその形を覚えているんです
一回見たら でも思い出す場合はなかなか思い出せません
また同じものを見たら
あ これですよと認識できますけどね
だからこの脳のその働き使用しているんです
ものを見ると形を記録する
また見るとまた記録する
そうやってずっと記録させておくんです
ある量に記録してしまったら
目を閉じても脳が同じ反応を起こすんです
目を開けていた時 脳を起こす同じ反応目を閉じても起こすんです
視覚として そこで人には目を閉じてもそれ見える
だからある程度それ変なんですけど
そこで何を考えてるかというと
このそこは集中していないとできないことなんですね
一つの仕事を長い間やり続けないと生まれない現象なんです
ですから このもう一部は変なことなんですけど
一部ではいい結果があるんですね
集中力っていうもの だから変なものを見ると驚きますけど
集中力からは大変喜びと楽しみとリラックスが生まれてくるんですね
そうやって目で見たものを目を閉じても見えたところで
自分がもっと落ち着く場所に引っ越しするんです
場所関係ない その場合は
例えばこの頭の瞑想というのは昼しかできないんです
昔だったら これ見なくちゃいけないんだから
夜は正しく見えない 今でも
人工の光だから だから昼しか瞑想できないというとね
それはちょっと困ったもんで
そこで目を閉じても見えるんだったら
まあ光が明かりがあってもなくても
夜でも朝でももう好きな時にできるんですね
そうやって それでその人はもう好きな場所により
もっと安全な場所に行って
目を閉じて これ目を閉じたところで見える対象を見ながら
また同じ瞑想を繰り返して繰り返す
さらにさらにそれを記録していくんです
で そこでたまたま混乱
集中力消えちゃったら
あれ消えちゃうんです
消えちゃったらまたやり直す
また対象を持って持って
また見て見て見て瞑想する
そうやってこの対象のコピーをちゃんと心で受け取るというステップまでやらなくちゃいけない
そこで受け取った心で受け取ったこの現象
その現象を見て瞑想する
そうすると その現象の中でもいろんな変化が起きるんです
そこですっごく気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
ちょっとした感情で もう頭で浮かんだ現象だからどうなるかわからないんですね
だからこういう瞑想っていうのは
この厳密にちゃんと経験ある人々の指導の下でやるもんなんです
で 固定概念やら文化背景やら
いろいろ人間のくだらない考え方なんか
そこで頭の中の働き だからもう入り込んじゃったらもう保証できないんですね
どうなるか そこでもし何かになったらもう直せないんです
かなりの心の心だけの働きですからね
だからこういう瞑想っていうのは
この仏教で言ってるこのものすごい
この あの なんていうか
論理的というかね 科学的っていうの
この感情とか美学的に物事を見るんじゃなくて
この私がこのすごい乱暴で説法してるでしょうに
何にも価値が入れます
全部 だから何ですかっていう感じで
それぐらいの心がないと
ものすごい厳密に科学性と具体性と合理性とはあって
どんなものを見ても だから何ですか？っていう何者かと
それぐらいこのちょっとしたもう性格がね
まず育ててほしいんで
だからそういうのはこの先生のところで弟子入りしてね
大体この瞑想にしたっても
やっぱり五 六年 七 八年
先生のところで弟子入りしなきゃやってはいけないと
先生がじゃああんたもう帰れと言われたところからもう瞑想を始めるんですね
だからそれぐらいこの人のこの心の一般的なね
この間違ってる心というかね
すぐ鵜呑みにする もう何でも信じ込む
このいい加減な心の状況をまず直してもらわないと
で やっぱりあの あまりよくないんです
これこの大変なチャレンジですからね
自分の心と ですから この心から
この心で このいわゆる脳細胞でこの対象をするようになったところから
この変化また起こる その変化はこのちゃんとした
このまあ経典ではもう仏教のもうとことん仏教を知ってる人々をもう何年ももう指導を受けて
弟子入りして教えてもらってもらってる人々をやるもんだから
このその過程しか書いてないんです
いい加減な人だったら
またいろんなことが起こります
そこは書いてないし 当時の人々は知らないしね
まあ大体どういう変化というと
そのものはね いろいろもう変わっていく
土色はもうどんどん汚くなっていく
で また汚いところはどんどん消えちゃって
また綺麗になっていく
どんどんこの本当の土色
純粋に土色のみ見えてくるんですね
まあそれも分かりませんだけど
幻覚は幻覚ですけど やっぱりまとめて綺麗に何の欠点もないように見えてくる
それから自分にはこのもうそれからすごく長い間
いろいろ訓練しなくちゃいけない
この心で受け取ったものはいとも簡単に蘇ることをできるように
ずっと続けてやると それでこの小さくある三十センチぐらいの円だから
そこはどんどん大きくしてみるんですね
だから頭のイメージだから大きくという気持ちが出たら大きくなる
だからと驚かないで それは自分の気持ち次第に大きくなるんだっていうことを理解して
もうちょっと大きくなるように見えるんですかと
それで大きくして大きくしてみる
だからといって自分にコントロールできないところまで大きくしてはいけません
だから もう無限に大きくなってほしいと言っちゃったら
もう自分の目の中で 頭の視覚の中で
土色のみ もうもうどうしようもなくなっちゃう
コントロールできなくなっちゃうんです
だからちゃんと境界線があって
感じられるように 自分に今我々にやっぱりものを見ると
適当な大きさあるんです
あまりにもでっかい絵だったら
もう見たって面白くも何もない
それは遠く 遠くへ遠くへ行って見なくちゃいけない
遠く行くと見えなく また帰って見えなくなる
全体的には見えるんだけど
パッと見ると見えなくなっちゃう
そこで近寄ってくると
あまり大きい絵だから
また全体的には捕まれなくなっちゃうし
ですから この人の目にちゃんと認識的に受け取れるって大きさがあるんです
それまた個人差があります
人間みんな同じだから同じ大きさでしっかり見えるわけじゃないんです
個人差もそれなりにあります
ですから その個人が自分にはしっかりと
またいくらかの大胆なスケールで大きく
でも掴まれるぐらいの大きさに大きくしてみる
また 自分の意識でコントロールして小さくしてみる
元のところに戻ってもらう
また大きくしてもらうとか
そうやって訓練するとかなり自分が上手になるんですね
この心で受け取ったこの対象
幻想現象ですか 幻想